now to Beaumont Texas which is
essentially cut off nearly every major
highway in and out of the city is either
closed or flooded the supply of drinking
water for more than a hundred and twenty
thousand people is knocked out causing a
dire situation and a Werner is in
Beaumont where evacuations are taking
place by air and a good morning good
morning Anthony there were hundreds more
people evacuated here from the Regional
Airport at Beaumont overnight including
an American Airlines flight that was
offered up by the company those people
had to leave Red Cross shelters here in
the city after the city lost its
drinking water that water lost of course
because the floodwaters overwhelmed the
city's pumping stations and that is a
dire situation as you said with no
drinking water it forced those people
who were in shelters taking refuge there
to leave you pray you ask for help and
maybe they can give us resources and
maybe we can get to higher ground maybe
we can feel safe
Trina LeDoux her stepfather and grandson
escaped flood waters in Port Arthur like
many families on the tarmac at Beaumont
Regional Airport they were told getting
to safety meant boarding c-130 military
planes and heading some 250 miles to
Dallas do you even know what you're
going to do next no we have no knowledge
of a hotel how are we going to get to
where we're going all we know is we're
going to be dropped into at it people
staying in the city's 3 Red Cross
shelters had to leave because there was
no running water even this major
hospital was forced to evacuate its
patients including infants buses that
were supposed to ferry evacuees from the
airport to San Antonio got turned around
flooded roads made the trip too
dangerous we've been ready to go
since we
I heard there was a major Justin Davis
is with the Texas Air National Guard
he says evacuations will continue around
the clock it's the logistics we're
coordinating with multiple civilian
agencies problems croc pup we put our
heads together and we come up with a
solution and we do it's right and we do
its best for the everyone while some
families told us they won't be returning
Trina LeDoux says Dallas won't be her
final destination you ever going back to
Port Arthur probably so because it's
still where we locate it's still home it
may not be soon but it's still home so
there is some water running in the city
for flushing toilets only some a little
bit of water coming out of the taps now
as the city and private companies work
to find some solutions to solving this
problem as quickly as possible there
were lines all over the city miles long
some of them as people lined up
desperately trying to get bottled water
for drinking the water by the way that
is coming out of the taps is not safe
for drinking it would have to be boiled
for a good long time before it could be
used for human consumption Dana all
right Anna Warner in Beaumont Texas Anna
thank you